qu'est-ce qu'il a pas hérité de vous
Vincent Cassel
super jeune parce que je suis pas si on
peut dire 92
Jean-Pierre Cassel incroyablement
conservait vous motorisez à le dire oui
bien sûr 72 non oui
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce qu'on apprend dans le livre
enfin si on ne savait pas si votre vrai
nom c'est Crochon oui hein alors sur vos
trois enfants il y en a deux qui ont
gardé le pseudo de Cassel c'est Vincent
et Cécile et puis il y en a un troisième
qui s'appelle Mathias Mathias Crochon il
en souffre pas ça va pas du tout je
crois pas il a il fait du rap il a il a
formé un groupe qui s'appelle assassin
et il se fait connaître sous le nom de
rocking squat alors ce qui est drôle et
ça aussi c'est dans votre bouquin Monica
Bellucci quand elle est en famille il
l'appelle Monique Crochon
vous la trouvez jolie manique très très
belle très très extrêmement belle mais
elle est surtout c'est une belle
personne surtout elle a pas un peu
grossir récemment non mais ça y est plus
ouais c'est parce qu'il s'est passé et
son accent ridicule vous trouvez face à
un support
italien magnifique
voilà
alors vous êtes grand père donc d'une
petite Deva qui est née le 12 septembre
à Rome alors c'est du sanskrit je crois
que c'est une le nom d'une divinité
indienne effectivement ça veut dire
beauté céleste en sanskrit donc elle est
bien nommée et Vincent ça va je crois
qu'il va très bien alors il y a un truc
très gentil dans la préface de votre
livre il dit qu'il était un jeune acteur
en colère j'ai tout fait dit-il en
parlant de vous pour me démarquer de son
image et puis j'ai réalisé l'influence
qu'il avait eu sur moi c'est c'est très
gentil quand même ça c'est une très
belle préface il a écrit un très très
joli texte qu'est-ce qu'il a pas hérité
de vous Vincent Cassel
ma patience
il est plus impatient que moi il est
moins bien élevé je ne dirais pas ça je
dis qu'il est plus il est plus sanguin
que moi donc la quête il est pas au top
il est moins bien que moi il est bien
meilleur sur beaucoup d'autres choses
qu'est-ce qui vous énerve le plus chez
lui ce qui me fait beaucoup rire mais ça
c'est un peu dans la famille c'est sa
mauvaise foi que que je partage avec lui
alors ça fait beaucoup rire enfin bon
courir ça énerve pas mal les femmes de
la famille mais on en joue beaucoup quoi
ça nous amuse beaucoup en fait il y a un
truc que vous avez jamais osé lui dire
et que vous auriez envie de lui dire ce
soir
par exemple que tu n'es pas son vrai
père un truc de famille un peu j'hésite
beaucoup à lui dire
il aurait du mal à un truc un peu perso
profite de la télé
non pas vraiment jour on sait on se
parle beaucoup je crois que je vais tout
ce qu'il fallait dire au moment où il
fait quoi et Cécile Cassel qu'on adore
ici qui vient sans arrêt est-ce qu'il y
a quelque chose que vous avez envie de
lui dire
et bien d'être patiente d'être patiente
et de et de croire
en s'abonner toi voilà mais des deux
c'est lequel ton préféré
qu'est-ce qu'elle est belle en tous les
cas oui très belle
ma fille
alors Jean-Pierre Cassel vous publiez à
mes amours chez Stock où vous racontez
votre vie à travers vos acteurs vos
réalisateurs vos auteurs vos chanteurs
vos amis vos femmes vos enfants enfin
tous ceux qui l'ont qui l'ont marqué et
on y retrouve votre célèbre légèreté qui
est dues vous à un certain fatalisme
vérité de mon père sans doute qui était
médecin généraliste
une un certain fatalisme je crois je
crois qu'il n'arrive que ce qu'il doit
arriver et je pense qu'on peut orienter
quelquefois certains événements qu'on
peut qu'on peut un petit peu de tordre
le cou à certaines vérités à certaines
réalités mais qu'en fait la vie que vous
avez c'est la vie qui est écrite quoi
vous dites il y a des choses comme
l'érosion des sentiments auxquels on ne
peut pas échapper mais le reste on peut
essayer de l'améliorer voilà c'est très
positif ça oui positif
vous allez jusqu'à rendre dommage dans
le bouquin à votre première femme qui
vous a quitté en disant bah oui ça se
passait mal elle est partie finalement
c'est une bonne chose alors sur le
moment j'ai passé aussi drôle que ça non
c'est pas drôle
qu'on réalise après coup et si on est si
on est honnête effectivement sur le
moment c'est pas c'est pas du tout
agréable et je l'ai vécu comme beaucoup
de gens doivent le vivre mais que c'est
vrai qu'avec le recul
si votre vie se déroule mieux et où
débouche sur des horizons auxquels vous
aviez pas pensé on ne peut que remercier
ce qui s'est passé avant de connaître la
seconde femme exactement
mais même la maladie dont vous sortez
vous arrivez à y trouver du positif oui
je sais que j'arrive à y trouver je suis
bien obligé je pense que les les je
pense que les coups durs qui vous
arrivent ça ne sert à rien de de lutter
contre et de dire ah oui mais en ce
moment je peux pas faire ça je loupe ça
et tu sais je crois que c'est pas du
tout le propos le propos c'est de
prendre les choses qui vous arrivent et
de les essayer de les résoudre comme si
c'était quelque chose qu'on a envie de
faire voilà et la maladie pareil quoi
voilà ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'on
gagne c'est simplement que ça aide c'est
tout en tous les cas je dirais grâce à
cette maladie d'une certaine façon vous
avez les cheveux courts oui j'ai écrit
le livre ouais et j'ai et j'ai sans
doute révisé pas mal de de mes
comportements et de jugement par rapport
à mon entourage et par rapport à aux
gens en général parce que on s'aperçoit
que comme on dit on remet les choses en
perspective quoi tout d'un coup on
s'aperçoit que beaucoup de choses sont
peu d'importance par rapport à ce qui
peut vous arriver
voilà ça va là ça va bien ça va bien
les cheveux courts
je suis très fier de ça me fait très
plaisir alors dans le livre vous parlez
évidemment de tous les gens qui vous ont
marqué Fred Astaire il y a une phrase
vous dites que c'est une image
fondatrice pour vous en habit en cravate
blanche avec un huit reflets sur la tête
c'est à dire à haute forme il marche la
nuit dans une ville sur une musique de
Jérôme cairn ça pour vous c'est une
image oui c'est une image qui m'a
beaucoup marqué c'est magnifique et vous
racontez quand vous rencontrez Jane
Kelly sur la piste du club Saint-Germain
et alors là vous l'invitez chez vous à
votre anniversaire il dit oui oui il dit
oui parce que c'est un homme très simple
et il est venu chez moi parce que
c'était un type qui venait en France il
était curieux de rencontrer les gens il
m'avait connu au club Saint-Germain il
dit bah oui j'ai à l'anniversaire de
Jean-Pierre et c'est là il m'a montré un
pas de claquette que je continue à faire
d'ailleurs un Américain à Paris et puis
les réalisateurs alors ce qui est très
très bizarre si vous n'ayez jamais
tourné avec Jacques Demy
[Musique]
interprètes de me satisfaisait pas alors
il y a une scène terrible dans votre
bouquin c'est quand vous êtes tous les
deux chez Castel et il prend un verre
comme ça un verre de vin rouge il l'a
dans la main il le sert comme ça et le
vert explose et d'un seul coup vous
dites vous découvrez un personnage que
vous soupçonniez pas du tout une très
grande force intérieure et une très
grande oui c'est quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un qui est très très intense et
qui je crois qu'il m'aimait beaucoup on
s'aime toujours beaucoup d'ailleurs
c'est mais que je lui disais des choses
pas agréables et au lieu de de projeter
sa colère vers moi et ben il a pété le
verre alors c'est bizarre parce que vous
vous séparez vous vous retrouvez pour
chouan et vous dit on se quittera plus
jamais et puis après vous restez 23 ans
sans faire quoi que ce soit ensemble
c'est c'est bizarre c'est bizarre c'est
bah les scénaris qui ne correspondent
pas à ce qu'on attend quoi à vous parler
de votre grand amour de jeunesse
Françoise Dorléac sœur de Catherine
Deneuve donc un jour vous apprenez
qu'elle s'est tuée sur la route en
allant à l'aéroport de Nice vous
réagissez pas vous restez sec et vous
finalement c'est bizarre je suis pas je
suis pas ému et vous réalisez sa mort un
jour en vous garant devant repas c'était
que votre mère d'ailleurs plus tard et
voilà et c'est assez à ce moment-là que
j'ai réalisé ce que ce à quoi elle
correspondait et le manque qu'elle a
laissé alors voilà vous racontez votre
vie avec Cassel vous n'avez pas assez du
temps chez castelvin oui beaucoup hein
Cassel chez Castel Pierre Bénichou
c'était vraiment les un vraiment les
acolytes vous faites toutes vos fêtes
là-bas les 10 ans avec Anne Cassel c'est
chez Castel tous les grands événements
sont chez Castel etc et vous parlez de
cette danse qu'on adore qui s'appelle la
Bostella
pourquoi je sens de l'ombre vous m'avez
d'appeler voici revoilà mais pour
fabriquer plus la nuit est de gros
[Musique]
c'est-à-dire que ça commence comme ça
avec des comme des sardas comme ça pour
l'allégresse
ils sont comme ça sur eux-mêmes ils
tapait des mains et puis au moment où ça
devient langoureux et tout tout le monde
tombait par terre les uns sur les autres
il y avait une espèce de magma humain
vous êtes des gens se ressembles d'un
coup ça reprenait tout le monde sur levé
et ça a été pendant quelques mois je
crois chez Castel une espèce de folie
une vraie folie il y a eu des enfin des
poignées cassés des des bleus des
montres volées des mains basales
baladeuses c'était absolument
hallucinant comme c'est un mec qui
s'appelait honoré Boston perdre très
très intelligent journaliste de grand
grand talent et qui avait eu cette idée
là un soir comme ça alors ce que j'ai
appris en lisant votre bouquin c'est que
vous avez et au théâtre nu devant
Giscard d'Estaing sur la scène du Palais
royal de Jean-Michel Rosières c'est une
pièce où vous étiez le personnage arrivé
croyant avoir rendez-vous avec son
masseur il rentrait nu sur scène et il
tombait sur Annie Duperey qui était en
fait une
un soir dans la salle effectivement et
ce qui m'a beaucoup amusé c'est
qu'effectivement le Square où il était
là il s'est arrangé pour se tourner
discrètement vers ma femme qui était
derrière comme ça à ne pas regarder du
tout le plateau
alors on va rester dans le théâtre
puisque vous êtes sur scène en ce moment
mettez à l'atelier dans une pièce qui
s'appelle à la folie pas du tout
d'edware Albi celui qui a fait Virginia
Woolf alors à partir d'une question à la
fois simple et compliquée tu m'aimes
voilà et c'est un couple qui se rend
compte qu'ils sont plus sur la même
couleur
très très brève et très très caustique
et très
pleine de sens chaque fois et où on
découvre peu à peu la vérité de ce
couple
qui est pas forcément très très drôle
mais c'est traités sur un mode votre vie
laisse puisque Albi a mis en sous-titre
de sa pièce et votre ville en français
et la pièce fait beaucoup rire et sans
doute beaucoup réfléchir c'est très
étonnant sur le plan de la mise en scène
c'est il y a un qui a fait la mise en
scène c'est qu'à un moment il y a un
panneau qui descend avec marqué
identifier vous et donc les acteurs
s'identifient c'est ça je m'appelle
Jean-Pierre Cassel se présente moi
j'étais très inquiet de cette histoire
parce que je trouvais ça je sais pas
très dérangeant que je dis comment
publier va réagir et il se trouve que
c'est un des moments de la pièce où les
gens adorent absolument ça les fait
beaucoup beaucoup rire parce que ça
dépend à contre-pied que tout d'un coup
voir ces deux acteurs qui ont joué
monsieur et madame tout le monde enfin
un couple comme ça se présenter elle
arrive je m'appelle Daniel Lebrun je
suis comédienne etc et ça c'est l'effet
hurlait de rire
Jean-Pierre Cassel mes amours
et la pièce s'appelle à la folie pas du
tout c'est tous les jours au Théâtre de
l'Atelier
alors c'est un livre léger donc comme je
l'ai dit parfois même superficiel alors
vous n'échapperez pas ce soir
Jean-Pierre Cassel à quelques questions
de fond on va vous faire une art review
[Musique]
quand vous regardez le matin dans la
glace vous dites quoi
je trouve que
des matins je me trouve assez en forme
et d'autres pas du tout vous auriez aimé
ressembler à qui quand vous étiez petit
j'ai pas je me suis jamais posé la
question je j'avais envie de capitaine
boulimique je j'ai fait mon ce métier
parce que je
j'adorais Daniel Gélin Gérard Philipe
Haribo enfin je veux dire que alors j'ai
pas voulu ressembler à quelqu'un je
voulais avoir la possibilité de me
multiplier et d'être tout et tout et
tout le monde quoi vous avez pleuré
quand pour la dernière fois
je pleure pas mal moi je pleure facile
je pleure je
trouve que je te connais entouré de
choses tellement monstrueuses que
je crois qu'il est difficile de ne pas
pleurer quelquefois sur ce que nous
représentons nous les hommes voilà vous
diriez quoi depuis négatif sur vous
que je manque de
je vais peut-être pas au bout des choses
que je me je me reproche souvent de ne
pas aller au bout des choses sur votre
carrière par exemple vous pensez que
vous auriez pu faire une plus grande
carrière en fait j'ai réussi ce que je
voulais depuis le départ inconsciemment
c'est à dire faire ce métier en
m'amusant bonjour en gardant le l'envie
le fait et en rencontrant le plus de
monde possible qui me passionne voilà si
votre vie était à refaire qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez pas de la même façon oh
mon dieu
je sais pas je regrette rien en fait non
non je regrette rien je regrette que ça
se termine un jour c'était aujourd'hui
qui avez-vous le plus envie des pâtés
mes enfants mes enfants ma femme enfin
les gens que j'aime
j'adore quand bah oui quand je l'ai
quand je les ai pas encore j'adore ça
bien sûr quelle est la dernière chose
que vous faites le soir avant de vous
coucher
j'essaye un petit parc claquette sur la
moquette pour voir si je me rappelle
toujours c'est vrai oui oui c'est bien
tu imagines
et puis surtout sur la moquette et pieds
nus on apprend bien parce qu'on sent
bien le sol et qu'est-ce que la vie vous
a appris
on apprend à vivre tout simplement elle
vous apprend à vivre est-ce que vous
avez une meilleure opinion de vous
aujourd'hui qu'à l'âge de 20 ans oui
nettement nettement vous allez menti la
durant cette interview je ne crois pas
vous regrettez d'être venu non
[Musique]
monsieur et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu